Russia says 11 people have been killed
in a shooting at its Southern border
with Ukraine the defense Ministry says
two attackers opened fire at a military
training ground in belgorod the area has
been shelled in recent days in what
Russian officials say were missile
strikes by Ukrainian forces
a terrible event happened yesterday on
our territory on the territory of one of
the military units there was a terror
attack committed many soldiers were
killed and wounded all of the Wounded
are getting help I want to express my
words of condolence to the families of
those who were killed we are by your
side well let's talk now to Muhammad Val
who is in Moscow for so Muhammad what
more do we know about this
this hasn't we know that it happened
over the night and that the defense
Ministry uh at the beginning they said
people but now the governor is of the
area is saying soldiers but it's not yet
clear whether they are Russian soldiers
or Russian trainees or foreign trainees
because the the two men who opened fire
were identif identified as uh belonging
to one of the CIS countries the central
the Commonwealth of independent nations
including Tajikistan which has been also
mentioned by a Russian independent
website that said the the uh the the the
attack took place not in the city of
belgorod itself but in a town called
soloti to the southeast 105 kilometers
to the southeast of belgorod and other
sources talking about Tajikistan as the
country from which those two attackers
came Russian media Russian official and
a state sponsored media they all
mentioned that this is a terrorist
attack and they put it along with the
other attacks on Belgard that have been
taking place during the last several
weeks and particularly yesterday they
all they mentioned that all of these
attacks are actually terrorist attacks
the ukrainians of course have rarely
taken responsibility of those of those
attacks but Russians are talking about
them as terrorists they also talk about
the bridge what happened at the bridge
as a terrorist attack and what we know
is that they they said that no civilians
have been killed at all the wounded are
being treated the dimension of soldiers
has we had that only today but they were
talking only about trainees we know that
the mobilization has triggered a lot of
anger here in Russia and at the site
there one of those sites in Belgard and
near belgorod have been you used as
training grounds for the newly mobilized
Russians and incidents took place across
Russia including
opening fire on on recruitment centers
and direct confrontations between
protesters and the military so I mean in
some sources this is framed as a part of
the ongoing anger against mobilization
but officially it is framed as a
terrorist attack all right Muhammad
thanks for that Muhammad in Moscow for
us